in today's society 2019 your opinion
what are the three most pressing
obstacles that we face as Americans okay
well I think the number one issue that
comes to mind is the inability to have
conversations we're now living in a
world where even the willingness to have
conversations is seen as something bad
when you live in a democratic republic
where we're all supposed to vote based
on the outcomes of those discussions if
you aren't even willing to sit down with
somebody on the other side of the aisle
and have a conversation it makes it
impossible for you to vote in an
informed way and it makes it impossible
for you to see her neighbor as somebody
who's not a jerk it makes it impossible
for you to even have the social fabric
necessary to serve as the root of a
civilization and you see this I mean
there's an there's an unbelievable
article the New York Times this op-ed in
the New York Times maybe three four days
ago in which they named check me the
name checked a bunch of other people who
are in the so-called intellectual dark
web and they said all these people keep
asking for discussion and debate
just like slaveholders would and I was
like whoa I'm pretty sure that the thing
that the slaveholders did wrong was the
owning of the slaves you know like that
the raping and the beating and like the
owning of humans like that was probably
the problem me saying I want a
discussion is actually not like that but
the goal for a lot of folks right now is
shut down the conversation make it so
that people can't talk with you and then
excise people from public life and make
it impossible for them to work and look
I'm lucky I get to talk for a living and
I make a good living doing it but there
are a lot of people out there who don't
have the option of having a microphone
in their face saying their opinion and
they're just trying to get through the
day and they're afraid that if they say
something at work people are gonna come
down on them destroy their lives try and
have them fire that's really not good
for the country we at least have to see
each other as common as friends right we
have to each other as emitter as
Americans if we want to have those
conversations so to me and it's
happening on the right and the left I
think right now is happening more on the
political left than the political right
because of the the sort of woke nature
of politics and the new rules that are
constantly changing and you cross a line
didn't even know was there and suddenly
something you said back in 2010 it for
Kevin Hart means you lose a job at the
Oscars right and that this is how I end
up on the same side as Dave Chappelle
with I'm sure the Dave Chappelle and I
disagree on a lot of stuff and on this
stuff we are on the same page now that
that's because the lines are being drawn
in harsh and terrible fashion there's no
such thing as
there's no such thing as an honest
conversation where you just go to
somebody like you know that thing you
said 10 years ago I thought that was
really offensive and persons like you
know me too like I wish I hadn't said
that yeah that's just kind of gone and
that's really dangerous and bad so that
would be problem number one that I see
facing the country we've talked about
that a lot in this show you've actually
said almost verbatim that you think
that's the most dangerous thing
affecting I think I think in in in
conversation it's huge when it comes to
entertainment but I also believe it's
the biggest obstacle we face from a
legislative standpoint is the inability
of the right and the left to come
together and make any meaningful change
through compromise we just have separate
aisles where the left may even no and
I'll use the left just why not the left
may even know that something the right
is proposing is the right answer to a
problem and they simply will not make a
compromise just because it's the right
that's proposing it and vice versa and
so we're at we're at a stalemate and
impasse whatever you want to call it I
was talking with a friend of mine who
teaches over Wharton Business School
maybe a couple of weeks ago and he said
if you want to have a good conversation
with someone you start with the solution
if you don't have a bad conversation
with someone start with the problem and
what you see in politics these days is
that the easiest way to get people to
love you and to be interested in you is
you label a problem and then you say
it's a big problem and the other person
says well but I don't like your solution
K well that's cuz you're not taking the
problem seriously enough if you really
were serious about the problem well I
think we can all acknowledge the we're
all serious about the same problems take
gun control I think we're all very
serious about no one wants to see
innocent people shot at a Walmart we're
all on the same page there no one wants
to see innocent kids gunned down in a
classroom we have different solutions to
that and we should be clear about what
we think those solutions are but
politicians aren't in the business of
trying to be clear or be specific
because then we can either think it's a
good idea or a bad idea they're in the
business of trying to castigate to hit
the moral character of somebody on the
other side for political gain and that
that does hold true for both sides I've
been railing against this for a long
time that these sort of we disagree
therefore you're morally inferior point
of view and it bears real political
fruit the best politicians are really
good at this and they do it do you know
I think Trump does it I think the
Democrats do it I think that I think
pretty much everybody does it it's an
easy buck do you think that that
ideology in that poll
from political candidates was what kind
of led to the Trump presidency and do
you think that Trump as a president is
more divisive than then those that came
before him less more polarizing I mean
he's definitely more divisive and
polarizing but I think that he's a
symptom not the cause so I don't think
the world started spinning on in
November of 2016 in other words I think
that Trump happened for a reason and it
happened cuz a lot of people were
supremely pissed off because they'd been
told for years your voice doesn't matter
no one cares about you you're outside
the mainstream you can't you can't be
part of this conversation and those
people got sick of it and they were like
okay f you and after you came in the
form of Trump I mean Trump is not a
person who knows anything about policy
he doesn't have a conservative
philosophy he brags that he's written
more books than he's read I mean this is
not somebody who people elected because
they're like wow what amazing ideas yet
they elected him because he was a giant
pulsating middle finger to the
establishment in a variety of ways right
to an establishment in the media that
said we can't have conversations to an
establishment that that established
these these kind of rules of political
correctness that he was constantly
railing against and wasn't I think that
Trump fails to make the distinction and
and I talked about this a lot in 2016 I
think he fails to make the distinction
between being politically incorrect and
just being a jackass right there is a
difference like being politically
incorrect is saying things that have to
be said because they have to be said and
if it offends people so be it being a
jackass is saying things that don't need
to be said just to be a jackass and
there is a difference between those two
things and it's easy to conflate them
and you see Trump do this on a fairly
regular basis but he is a result of
people feeling hemmed in and the result
of that is that he busts loose a lot of
things I think some of that busting
loose was necessary and good I think
that he's also unleashed some some real
the kind of Freudian heed in American
politics and everybody's ramped it up I
mean you've seen it it I thought it was
bad in 2015 2016 we had riots in 2015
right mm but I think that you're you
just sing it ramp up and ramp up and
ramp up to the point where it feels like
something has to give I mean I think
everybody has that feeling like
something has tits um this has to calm
down somehow right and it's not calming
down unfortunately